-Our next guest is
a very funny comedian and actor
you can see in the film
"Easter Sunday,"
and who will be headlining
Madison Square Garden
November 10th as part of
the New York Comedy Festival.
His latest special,
"Jo Koy: Live from
the Los Angeles Forum,"
is streaming now on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-He goes, "Dad,
I'm not gonna throw a party.
I promise.
I won't invite anybody."
I go, "Listen to me.
Just hear me out.
If you throw a party, Joe,
and one of your friends
jumps into the pool
and breaks [bleep] --
breaks their neck,
they're gonna sue me.
And everything
I worked so hard for
to give to you when I don't --
when I leave this Earth..."
[ Light laughter ]
"...is gonna go
to Dip [bleep] Dave..."
[ Laughter ]
"...because he dove
into the shallow end
at 2:00 in the morning
with the lights off.
Do you want to give everything
to Dip [bleep] Dave?"
-Please welcome to the show
Jo Koy, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I'm so happy to have you here.
-Oh, finally, man.
-Yeah! I'm really such a fan.
And I'm so impressed when people
can not just do one of these
but one after the other,
the other.
This is your fourth
Netflix special.
What was the inspiration when
you set out to do this hour?
-This one, I finally got to --
I felt like I was in a place
where I can finally
just say everything.
You know?
-That's a nice place to be at.
-Yeah, it --
'Cause it was hard.
In the first special, I --
you know,
I was turned down by Netflix.
-Yeah.
-And I didn't understand why.
And they told me no,
and I went and shot it myself.
I paid for it.
And then --
No one knows this,
and I keep telling this story,
but it's like -- I had all
the cameras in the building,
I had the director, I had the
producers all in the building.
We're ready to shoot, and we get
a phone call from Netflix,
and they go --
and they were like,
"Hey, we heard you're about
to shoot the special.
We just want you to know,
we really don't want it."
[ Laughter ]
And, like, I --
Just imagine the pressure.
It's like, that was the only
person I wanted to sell it to.
I wanted to sell this
to Netflix,
and they were already saying no.
They haven't even seen it yet.
And backstage, I'm crying,
you know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-I got all my money invested.
And I -- I was gonna shoot it
no matter what.
And I knew once I shot it
and cut it and showed them,
they were gonna buy it,
and that's what happened.
-What an amazing start
to this whole thing.
And now I'm assuming,
with the fourth one,
you have
a little bit more confidence.
You're probably not crying
before the show.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And then it was at
the Forum, too,
so it was like 14,000 people.
And I told the story
about how they didn't
give me the first one.
-Yeah, there you go.
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
And I would imagine
the location, the L.A. Forum,
is a cool place to do it
because you used to --
I mean, your pre-stand-up jobs,
your pre-acting jobs,
were right around that area.
-Exactly!
Hey, thanks, Seth!
[ Laughter ]
What?! Thank you.
-I remember, I think I was at
Nordstrom Rack
when you were working there.
[ Laughter ]
-I was at Nordstrom Rack!
I had three jobs.
My son was like 1, and I --
You know,
there's Nordstrom Rack,
and then right above that
was Borders Books.
-Yep.
-I was just doing
disposable jobs, so, like,
if I got a gig
and they wouldn't let me go,
I'm like,
"All right, I'll just quit."
-Yeah.
-And, uh, and I would drive by
the Forum and just look at it
like, "Oh, that'll never happen,
but I hope it happens."
And, yeah,
I get "The Tonight Show,"
I get a standing ovation.
-That's really cool.
-And I didn't know
how many people watched
"The Tonight Show" --
This is before YouTube
and all that was really big.
And it was like every other
customer walked up to me
and was like, "Oh, my God!
You were on 'The Tonight Show'
last night. You were so funny."
I'm like, "Thank you."
They're like,
"Can I get this in an 8?"
[ Laughter ]
-You worked really hard,
and I'm very happy to see
that your teenage son
is also working.
Now, how did he get this job
right here?
He's on the crew
for the Jo Koy tour.
-Aww.
-Look at that.
That's really cool.
-That's gonna make me --
Yeah, that's making me sad
to look at it, too.
It's like --
It's a great moment
to have your kid
on the road with you.
Especially me 'cause, like,
I was a road dog for so long.
-Yeah.
-I missed a lot of birthdays.
I missed a lot of Christmases.
I had to, you know?
And I had to feed him.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But now he sees why I did it
and how hard I worked.
-It must be so fun
to be able to do your job
and also
have family around like that.
-Yes, I love it.
He grounds me.
I don't --
I just want to hang out with him
as much as I can, and --
-Yeah.
-The cool thing is,
is he's famous.
He has to get the merch out
before they open the doors up,
because he'll be out there for
like two hours taking pictures.
But the cool thing is, is I
can't fire him, and he knows it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's what sucks.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it's like
I go in my green room,
and he's laying on the couch.
I'm like, "What are you doing?"
He's like, "Uh, what?"
[ Laughter ]
"What are you gonna do,
send me home, Dad?"
[ Laughter ]
-Speaking of the other side, you
know, obviously you're a parent.
Your mom --
you talk about your mom.
Has she seen it?
-Yeah.
-How does she feel when you talk
about her in your routine?
-She loves it.
-That's great.
-Yeah, she's love it.
And rightfully so.
She's lived here for so long,
and, you know,
you live in this country,
and you work hard, and --
and you go and watch TV,
and you don't see anybody
that, you know, is being --
you know, that plays a character
that looks like you
or sounds like you --
you know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-For 53 years, she watches TV,
and she doesn't
see a Filipino ever.
And the one time
she does see it, it's her son.
-Well, that's not bad.
-Yeah.
-That's not a bad way
to check that box.
[ Applause ]
-Yeah.
-Speaking of,
you went back and did shows.
You went on tour and you did
shows in the Philippines.
I can't imagine how they feel
when you show up there.
-That was nuts, man.
The first time I went,
we sold out the arena
and then shot a special there,
'cause I asked Netflix
if I could shoot one there.
And they let me.
[ Laughter ]
And then --
And then, I just recently --
I was there two weeks ago,
and we sold 10,000 tickets
on a Wednesday.
-Wow, man.
That's really something.
-Yeah, it was crazy.
-That is not
an easy thing to do.
-No.
-But I imagine --
I mean, I feel like
they're getting, you know,
two for the price of one,
in that they, one,
get to see a comedian they love,
obviously.
And also, you know, it's someone
that they can be extra proud of.
It must be just a great night
for them, as well.
I'm sure their money well spent.
-Thank you, man, thank you.
-I also wanna --
Before you go,
you've got a movie,
"Easter Sunday."
-That was crazy!
The way I got "Easter Sunday"
is, my second Netflix special,
"Coming in Hot,"
Steven Spielberg watched it.
-Uh-huh.
-And then -- And then they
called us in for a general.
And I thought it was just
a general for Amblin.
-Yeah.
-And I thought I was just gonna
go in there, be a general.
I pitch me, I pitch my story,
they tell me about them,
and then we just leave
and forget the whole thing
happened, right?
And I walk in, and it was like,
every single person's like,
"Oh, Steven loves you.
Oh, my God.
Steven can't stop
talking about your special.
Steven loves you.
Oh, my God.
Steven can't stop
talking about your special."
And I'm like,
to the point where I'm like,
"Are you talking about
Steven from accounting?"
[ Laughter ]
"Is there a Filipino
named Steven
that's bragging about me?"
[ Laughter ]
"I wanna meet this Steven."
And they were like,
"No, it's Mr. Spielberg,
and he wants
to make a movie with you."
And I pitched "Easter Sunday."
It was a movie I've been
thinking about for a long time,
and they bought it in the room,
and --
And it's kind of cool
to have the G.O.A.T....
-Yeah.
-...be on your side,
because the minute he bought it,
he was like,
"Oh, we're making it,
like, now."
And it was that fast.
He only made "Jurassic World"
and -- and my movie.
[ Laughter ]
And you know how cool that was
to take my son
to watch "Jurassic World"
and, like, my --
my trailer opened that movie.
It was just --
it was such a surreal moment.
-Ah, well,
it's really all well-earned.
You put in the hours,
and thank you so much
for making time for us tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Jo Koy, everybody!
"Jo Koy: Live from
the Los Angeles Forum"
is streaming now on Netflix.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."